not solution member of the Nobel
Committee for physics inventions were
awarded today it was about the tools
made of life sounds actually like
science fiction can you say something of
the history behind the optical tweezers
for example I think that author Ashkan
very soon after the first laser had been
constructed realized that suddenly there
was available a tool of light or the
totally different quality than you had
earlier and he started to think about
how can one use this tool to manipulate
objects and he realized that by thinking
about this he realized that just take a
small micro sized
transparent sphere it should be possible
even if the radiation pressure from the
laser is very small it should be
possible to manipulate such a sphere and
indeed he was correct and already 1970
he had demonstrated this so that but
then of course that was a long
development one development that that
went into the direction of manipulating
atoms something much smaller than than
microsites feared but he also started to
think about something much more complex
than a sphere namely viruses bacteria
even living cells he could trap so that
and that was of course the real
breakthrough that one could manipulate
such very complex objects same time you
can say that the dream of using
radiation pressure for example like
solar arrays is banking if you go a long
time back I mean already clipped Kepler
realized that radiation pressure from
the Sun could explain how the comet
tails are behaving when they are coming
in and out in the neighborhood of the
Sun so indeed it is you know it is an
older subject but it was really the
invention of the laser that put it into
the laboratory prior to that I mean you
didn't have light sources that would
work
laser so would it be possible to use
optical tweezers in moving objects in
space for example you mean up in out in
space I guess so I haven't thought about
that direction really but in space I
mean I guess there you want to have if
you want to have more than one spaceship
you what you really need is to keep them
extremely precise with respect to each
other and that laser of course plays a
very important role and this is a
development I think we will see in the
next 20 years for example in in in
space-based detectors for gravitational
waves and that a laser place on an
extremely important event and the other
part of this year's prize is about high
intensity lasers very short pulses why
did they want to develop such things and
I think there are several reasons I mean
if you saw the curve I did that was the
sort of act up to over 15 years and as a
physicist you always want to go to the
new frontiers you want to push the pulse
intensity you want to go to higher and
higher intensity where you really start
to not only talk to the molecule or atom
but really - seriously influence it and
this is something that really started
with the invention of the CPA technique
because then you get bounces of
sufficiently high intensity so that when
interacting with atoms and molecules it
was no longer a small perturbation but
it was a drastic change of the electron
shell of the atom and this then led to
strong field physics and up to second
metrology in physics at the second
science so that was an important
application rather unexpected I would
say I mean around 1985 there was no no
clear understanding of what would happen
if you expose atoms to such strong
fields you can take a movie of what's
happening in the economy yes yes you can
start to take movies of the electron
motion in the molecule or atom and this
was of course science fiction for for a
long time so the curve in the
development of intensity for lasers and
it kind of never stopped how in can scan
those laser beams be I don't I don't I
don't see a showstopper right now I mean
the there will be new materials that
will mean new ideas how you can the
basic science it is understandable and
then it's the question of the scale and
how much you can how big you can do
things and so on and so I don't I don't
see that there is a this will go on and
that's what I indicated with the dashed
line I'm it's going on for for one more
decade
are those instruments of divisors Oh
high interest can be a very small
instrument that's more like a microscope
the CPA based lasers I as I didn't I
didn't have time to show it here but it
can either be very very compact
instrument that you use for eye surgery
which is something that fits easily into
a I mean it's more it's not more bigger
than when you go to the dentist for
example I mean it's the same size of
instruments when you come to laser plus
my acceleration then we're talking about
really big lasers I mean filling up a
big laboratory but that's that's the
beauty of this technique is that it's
scalable it's scalable you can scale it
down if you want to have high rep rate
you want to have ultra precise
interaction with something for example
the eye or you want to drill though
you're going to make Stan's and so on or
you can emphasize really the high
intensity frontier and if you interact
the really highest intensity policies
with matter then of course you're
creating extreme conditions that doesn't
really exist on earth naturally but for
example may exist in in in astrophysics
in the interior of planets and so on so
that's that's direction I would call
laboratory astrophysics but still with
their other high rep right I mean one
Hertz is quite you know it's quite often
when you have this yes every second
Donna Strickland one of the laureates
this year is not only the third woman in
physics Nobel Prize history but also she
was a PhD student when she made this
intervention yeah
we have been a good advice for PhD
students today how to pick up important
dishes the work I think if you repeat is
if you're a potential PhD student you
should look for something that really
interests you you should look for groups
that are very good in that particular
area that interests you and then try to
start to get the PhD position in one of
these groups I think if you start with
something that you doesn't really
inspire you I don't think that's that's
not right then you're on the wrong wrong
track you should choose the topic first
then look for people that are doing this
and try to select the best it's not easy
admittedly but
thank you very much okay